and this season is also
why there are such serious ethical
questions
about sending asylum seekers
overseas
the details of for politics and
politicians
the principle
must stand the judgment of god
and it cannot
it cannot carry the weight of
resurrection justice
it cannot carry the weight of life
conquering death
it cannot carry the weight of the
resurrection
that was revealed first to the least
valued
for as a policy it privileges the rich
and the strong
and it cannot carry the weight of our
national responsibility
as a country formed by christian values
because subcontracting out our
responsibilities
even to a country that seeks to do well
like rwanda
is the opposite of the nature of god
who
himself took responsibility for our
failures
but imagine
this new world
suppose it is so
suppose the evil and injustice
which ukraine experiences is so dark so
deceitful
and so disgraceful has indeed been
defeated
because jesus is alive there is no magic
wand that makes everything right
but there is the promise
that the world of darkness is not
ultimately triumphant
and this causes us
who believe
that is of course the most reverend uh
justin will be there giving his easter
sermon in canterbury earlier there and
we had heard of course and we knew that
it was coming that he had criticized the
government's plans on asylum sending
immigrants to
rwanda and you heard there towards the
end of his address where he said
subcontracting out our responsibilities
to a country that seeks to do well like
rwanda is the opposite of the nature of
god who himself took responsibility for
our failings he did also mention that we
cannot carry out um the weights of the
um of those who
conquered god he also went on to say
that
we cannot of course
give out our responsibility and
basically give it out to other nations
to take care of that for us and that is
called of course talking about the
decision by the home secretary to
outsource immigrants to rwanda